[Musique]
alors ça je te le dis ça j'ai collé les
vestes blanches comme ça on a tous eu on
les met une fois la machine frère elle
devienne une couleur dégueulasse c'est
vrai je connais ça devient bleu tu es un
peu rosé c'est un drame
voilà je vous le dis donc voilà profites
en bien ouais ce que cela tue la micra
qu'une fois après elle va être un peu
chiffonné d'accord c'est la couleur de
la pure c'est ma mère m'a dit c'est pas
moi c'est toi que tu as bien capable
tenue ça fait longtemps effectivement
alors le mardi mme serait qu'on commence
toujours par une des séquences préférées
17 fans répertoriait de ma chronique
le zumba barrettes de thouars est de te
déprécier comme ça mais j'en ai huit
heures alors jean michel est venu un peu
le sniper de l'émission toujours dans la
finesse
le raf l'amour il syrie autant il ya des
jours où vous êtes très client du monde
jean michel bayle autant à des jours
vous êtes complètement hermétique à ses
vannes vous n'arrivez pas à le cacher en
fait c'est magnifique voici un zoom baba
franchement en ligue des champions
[Musique]
un petit copain au collège qui m'avait
écrit une lettre en dessin qu'on d'arts
plastiques avaient fait des des fleurs
y'a pas au rictus puis apple
tout est fabriqué un truc horrible alors
on a vu que la blague 2i donc de
jean-michel ça vous n'avez pas convaincu
n'ont pas fortement alors moi je reste
un grand fan de jean michel quand même
parce que riz c'est un peu le grand-père
que j'aurais aimé avoir
non mais oh il ya sa fille d'ô public
tiens ça non mais c'est ma petite soeur
en 5 dans l'émission est ce un petit
bout comme le tonton qui fait des vannes
à table en famille le dimanche
il sort des bonnes tout le temps et
forcément il ya ce qu'on appelle des
vannes perdu et comme d'habitude moi
j'adore voir la tête qui fait quand il
se rend compte que ça passe pas alors
voici comme chaque mois un épisode du
petit jean michel adam quand le petit
jean michel veut se moquer du
déguisement pourtant extraordinaire de
fabien lecoeuvre en sliman
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon de
la marine un naufrage
tu as trouvé ton rôle de captain igloo
leslie mann
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le petit jean michel à 2 vannes et
isabelle la bagarreuse mais l'humour du
petit jean michel est tellement fin que
personne ne le comprend pas ce genre est
arrivée faisait c'est lui l'homme mais
il avait les mots merde quoi c est alors
qu est ce que fait on quand le petit
jean michel veut donner des conseils
santé c'est encore une fois une petite
catastrophe
je vous en mets très d'autres bien sûr
tous les jours vous verrez il est
exceptionnel il faut dire aux
téléspectateurs ne pas de mettre de
persil dans l'auberge de personnes s'est
satisfait pas
[Musique]
dès qu'une petite nouvelle arrive dans
la classe le petit jean michel tombent
amoureux mais malheureusement plutôt que
de rouler une pelle c'est plutôt le
râteau très complices voilà pour moi je
passe quelque chose je sens que je pense
qu'elle va blanche fois qu'il se passe
quelque chose que toi de ton côté
ça fait mal
et pour finir le petit jean michel
continue à voir l'orthophoniste chaque
lundi et fait des progrès de diction
incroyable j'ai bossé tous les dvd
voilà c'était tous les dd
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi est très présent à la
télé ouais mais désormais décider très
présent sur la toile
à chaque dimanche pour se rapprocher de
son public et des lives sur instagram
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions et 5 il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont discuté avec lui dimanche
bon c'est vrai que si tous ces enfants
se connectent en même temps on est déjà
à dix mille personnes
mais je vais faire un petit résumé de ce
que benjamin nous en raconter tout ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est bien sûr dans tolérance réseau
c'est fort mais oui
alors benjamin c'est un papa gâteau qui
ses ventes des grandes qualités
intellectuelles de son fils tué dans la
maison
quelqu'un de l'adopter sinon il a 19 ans
et sympathique
on a fait des beaux gosses il est multi
fonctions il a un gros zizis donc l
embarras mais les comptines à tout faire
pour essayer de rejoindre l'équipe de la
grosse rigolade ses rivales superman
batman généralement bon jeu all c'est
maintenant les airs et surtout ferme à
nous donner un scoop on compose sans
arrêt de faire une émission un peu comme
les kardashian mais qui suivait la
nombreuse famille castaldi
moi j'ai eu au moins 400 propositions
qu'on nous suivre avec mon père avec mon
frère avec ma femme mes enfants mes amis
que si je fais ça je suis dead c'est là
qu'un doublement mon cul de montcuq
auquel tout le monde mon cul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup
pardon
oui alors donc non durant deux jours
vous allez savoir qui sera le 26e tard
baba surface un suspense incroyable mais
je vous montre chaque semaine la
vengeance des chroniqueurs qui s'attaque
à leur patron mais toujours dans le
respect en face à ça dépend qui même une
invitée s'est incrusté vous allez voir
c'est le ba-ba clash
tirs au but un ami un ami
il est ouais tu sais et je ne peux pas
avec laeticia hallyday en week-end et ma
mère de patois les images de la chaîne
je pense que vous devez rester sur ces
huit en plus il reste le dimanche où il
a pas d'émission avec vous un stage
commando
bien sûr j'ai fait de la route est resté
coi du style tu veux te montre donc je
vais pas vous dire qu'effectivement vous
n'avez pas cette preuve vous bluffer
donc j'ai mon prime time comme le filet
tu arrêtes de me faire chier
[Applaudissements]
faites moi le sport que sabrina autour
d'eux les bienvenus coup elle est ce que
je viens faire là dedans en train de
dire que ça prenne elle joue bien au
foot moi grave et est arrivé que tu me
défonce au tennis mais je te défonce au
foot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'humour
évidemment voilà merci on a quoi tu as
menée dans la grande marque vous aviez
pg je vous en croire que patrice laffont
l'avait traité je cite d'enculés alors
samedi
vous avez décidé de refaire la même quoi
pascal légitimus on enregistrait à vue
le père cela même insulte à propos de
lui alors autant jouer le père s'il
avait réagi en étant très énervés se
faire traiter autant pascal légitimus
lui était complètement déprimé il était
déprimé vous allez voir pascal le monde
de pascal légitimus s'effondre regarder
et c'est vrai quoi là on n'a pas compris
pourquoi tout ce regard des badauds sur
pascal légitimus il sera notre invité la
semaine prochaine pascal légitimus
aucune
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
mais lorsque voulais finir ce que j'ai
une nouvelle séquence quand vous avez
une nouvelle séquence funds comme savez
c'est comme un couple une chronique il
faut que ça soit pas la routine monsieur
alors la couleur qui vous plaît alors
pour un animateur faire la promotion
d'invités c'est un peu rébarbatif ferai
jamais employer des termes un peu qu'il
faut foncer corps je connais des mots
personnes en emploi mais chaque
animateur a sa propre façon de faire la
promo d'un film par exemple quand tu
sais faire la promo nos lives on a la
chance d'avoir l'objet en main donc ça
qui est cool d'un animateur il peut
montrer l'objet et faire la promotion en
même temps une fois de plus ici quand on
fait la pub d'un livre rien n'est fait
comme ailleurs
quand le monde de la littérature de la
science et de la danse se rencontrent sa
nouvelle séquence appel y a que chez
nous qu'on voit ça
alors d'on n'est pas couché laurent
ruquier présente les niveaux de finalité
de manière très sobre comme sa marque
après avoir conseillé évidemment sous le
sapin de noël pour vos jeunes le livre
de cristina cordula laurent delahousse
lui présent le livre de l'inviter en
faisant un résumé qui est plus long que
si tu lis le livre dans un style très
poétique car une vie de reclus
on retrouve cette idée de tribunal
populaire de ces réseaux sociaux de ces
éditeurs depuis devenu un mot qui
finalement est rentré dans l'inconscient
collectif dans l'émission les terres de
france 5 la grande librairie de françois
busnel quand il faut un thalys est on ne
peut plus classique
alors allons-y tient plongeon dans vos
livres si vous voulez bien marri
despléchin ne change jamais j'adore le
titre vient de sortir à l'école des
loisirs
mais quand cyril hanouna fait la promo
du livre des bogdanoff cédant ainsi
beaucoup plus contemporain
[Applaudissements]
me connaissent évidemment j'ai pas pu
résister à regarder ce qui se passe
[Musique]
m
mais
[Applaudissements]